here's something else from yaffe they
they tweeted during University of
Michigan inclusive leadership Workshop
Dr rushing Dr rushing struggles with
responding to Matt Walsh's what is a
woman question
um so this is some sort of some sort of
workshop at a university University of
Michigan and they're trying to deal with
this question and I always enjoy these
videos when we find them so here it is
if you're looking at the comment that
they shared was I was just sharing in my
group how one of my co-workers
challenged my identity using the trick
question of
what is a woman
and they unfortunately did not have a
chance to you know deal with their group
so I don't know if anyone has a way to
respond to like shut that down in the
moment
um like what how can we be the bystander
in that moment um how can we interrupt
the harm in action
um
sorry I'm
yeah so just this idea so like
asking someone like well what is a woman
which is just
gender is already a social construct so
they even asked that question just shows
that this person doesn't understand the
idea of like what gender is
um so many so many things that we
consider as truth
it's just how
that's just what the systems tell us
right
um now that I've had a chance to calm
down a little bit
um
if my first instinct would be if you
have the energy and again sometimes the
best thing to do is be like I'm gonna
engage with you is just walk away Rose I
am so sorry you have to deal with that
um
okay I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go off
right now
that's good it never gets old it never
gets old for me anyway it really never
gets old
um and they uh it's a trick question
right what is a woman what do you do
with this trick question it is I cannot
think of a question
that is less of a trick question than
what is a woman
or really anytime anytime you use a word
and someone says
what does that word mean
that is
there's no trick it is we want to know
what you mean by the words that you're
using what are you trying to communicate
you might not be able to answer it it
doesn't make it a trick question
um
but you notice it
even when they're talking amongst
themselves
uh they still they still struggle with
this question
because they can answer it for all the
reasons that we've covered extensively
um
but you see how
you see why they're so afraid to face
someone who is not in their club with a
question like this
because amongst themselves at least well
they're all on the same side they're all
in the same tribe
and no one is they all have the same
agenda no one's actually interested in
the truth they all understand that the
idea is to avoid objective reality and
objective truth
and they'll also take you know if when
they're talking about each other
they'll give each other the out
and so there there are just like talking
points or little slogans they'll throw
out something like
somebody someone brings up what is a
woman
they talk around it for a bit well you
know it's a trick question jitter's a
social construct and they throw out that
that slogan and then the other people
will say that are in the tribe oh yeah
sure okay
but if they're talking to someone's not
in the tribe uh well we're not going to
give you that out
it's not gonna be that easy you can't
just throw out a slogan and and have us
say oh well all right
because then you throw out the slogan
we're going to want to know you what you
mean by that slogan
oh gender is a social construct so it's
a what is so it's an invalid question
because what because the word woman
doesn't mean anything you're saying it's
just it's a constructed thing doesn't
mean anything
well so there why is anyone identifying
as it and why why should I respect it at
all
and still doesn't answer the question of
like what that person means when they
say it
so keep trying folks you're not there
yet you'll get there well you'll never
get there but keep trying for this one
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]